from the bombed out ruins of their
Community Club the survivors of one of
the most horrifying acts in this war
singing Lusty Defiance
The Villages of yahidne are about to be
the star Witnesses in Ukraine's biggest
war crimes trial to date
they fall silent
they're honoring those who didn't make
it through the largest single kidnapping
carried out by Russian troops during
their invasion of the country
the memories of what they've all been
through are still searingly raw
in the basement of the Village School
Russian soldiers held hostage almost the
entire community
Ivan was amongst nearly 400 villagers
held captive underground here for nearly
a month
the picture taken on their release shows
one of the bigger cells packed full of
hostages they were crammed in like this
all the time starved terrified and
tortured
368 villagers in all 69 of them children
the hostages were even crammed down the
corridor there were so many
everyone was sitting right up against
each other Ivan says they wrote there
were 55
the few photos taken when they were
found show how crushed they were they
spoke of being in the same position for
16 hours a stretch
they were split up amongst a network of
different sized cells with no hygiene
little air and just buckets to go to the
toilet in with all the rooms horribly
overcrowded
they put numbers on the outside of the
room there were 19 in here and look at
the size of this cell and no windows and
out of the 19 nine of them were children
there was no room to lie down or sleep
properly
no war the words say the children Drew
themselves with unhappy faces amongst
hopeful hearts and Ukrainian Flags
Ivan who was the school caretaker shows
us how they scribbled the national
anthem on the wall defiant in the face
of such Terror and there are other
pictures showing executions they feared
or witnessed few thought they'd get out
alive
it was really scary for the children and
grandchildren it was like a nightmare I
don't know how it got through it
the hidden is in the northern China
region near the Belarus border and was
stormed by Russian troops seven days
after the invasion began
the soldiers set up camp inside The
Village's only School turning it into
their headquarters the Big Sandy scars
on the school grounds are where they dug
in their military vehicles around the
perimeter
schools like hospitals are protected
under international law and hiding
inside to launch attacks is considered a
war crime holding civilians captive
inside a school and using them as human
Shields is also against Global rules of
warfare and the ukrainians say this is
exactly what the Russian soldiers did
during the 28 days of Hell in the school
basement
as The Villages were kept below ground
satellite images show us what was
happening above this image taken before
the Russians entered yehydney shows the
school to the left of the picture with
thick forest on its south west side
which gave cover to the invading
soldiers
a week into their occupation a large
number of military vehicles can be seen
by the school hidden beneath the trees
they're also parked between houses in
the village and you can see people in
the schoolyard
by the third week of the Russians being
a new hidney the pictures show the Army
units still positioned around the school
surrounding buildings have been
destroyed and the school's roof has been
damaged
on the school's top floors with the
Russian troops bedded in the fighting
was Non-Stop
there's a lot of damage here with holes
punched out
obviously evidence of rockets coming
through
the Ukrainian forces trying to push the
Russians out knew they were holding
hostages underneath and the captives
being held underground could only listen
helplessly to the fierce battles going
on above them
the Russians wanted to use us as
protection because they thought our
soldiers wouldn't shell us so they were
hoping they'd be safe
but we wanted them to Shell us to kick
the Russians out
and when the Russians were forced to
retreat a month later they left behind a
mass of evidence
we've been given rare access to what the
Ukrainian prosecutors found whole
military files a soldiers backpack
phones and SIM cards as well as
commanders orders
they've identified 15 Russian soldiers
that they believe violated the
international rules of War when they
were involved in the battle around
yahidna school we're trying to prove
that this large number of people more
than 360 were kept in the basement of a
school and used by the Russian troops as
human Shields against Ukrainian forces
and they're confident they have the
physical evidence left behind by the
soldiers
there are also hundreds of witnesses to
what happened inside the basement who'll
testify about the brutal conditions they
were held in which led to the deaths of
at least 10 of the hostages
the survivors held captive together a
staunchly patriotic and several told us
how their elderly neighbors and friends
died starving and weak with the Russian
guards just leaving the corpses amongst
them
whenever someone died we covered their
face just so we didn't have to look at
them but sometimes they lay there next
to us for 24 hours
[Music]
some of the children kept underground in
the dark amongst the corpses were babies
or toddlers
others like Marina and Lilia were young
teenagers when they were held captive
we went down there as children and we
left as adults with a very different
view about everything all our values
changed
you start to appreciate being healthy
being able to sleep in your own warm bed
not feeling hot but having fresh air and
being free
I try to tell everyone that everything
will be okay we will get out but the
others were saying they'll throw a
grenade down here they'll shoot us
they'll do something I believed they
wouldn't but when there's so much stress
you stop trusting yourself
[Music]
they weren't even safe when they were
allowed out to bury their dead
The Village priest who was amongst those
being held was given permission to leave
the basement to help dig the graves and
say the funeral prayers and he says even
then the Russians attacked them
we dug the grace but during the burial
we were shelled it was how do you say I
remember the first five or seven strikes
and then I got concussion and hurt my
shoulder and my back and other guys were
also injured
Ukrainian forensic investigators showed
us the new technological devices which
they're hoping will seal a guilty
verdict in the courts
they've taken thousands of images using
for the first time in the country a
range of 3D scanners to document what
happened inside
it's an incredible technological weapon
which freezes the crime scene forever so
forensic analysts lawyers and police can
minutely examine and zoom in on every
part of the investigation site all
Village was a hostage the investigators
worked with the team from the
international criminal court and with
the DNA collected and the 3D imagery
it's all expected to be used in a future
prosecution at the Hague we have
uh informations that uh
people killed there and they will just
put into the wood
and the forest and
nobody knows where these people are
actually if convicted those responsible
will be put on a global list of war
criminals and the Ukrainian teams are
hoping for early results
I want to hear the first verdicts this
year that's what I want and it's the
wish of millions of ukrainians too but
not just a verdict also punishment we
want the people guilty of these crimes
and murders and the Damage Done to our
country to take responsibility for their
actions by the end of the year
the whole village community is still
trying to get over a collective trauma
waiting for their day in court to tell
how a Russian Commander attempted to
bribe the starving villagers with baby
food and nappies if they agreed to give
false interviews
he said we need you to find someone
who'll be interviewed on Russian
television to say that we've saved you
and protected you from the ukrainians
and he said he wanted another interview
pulling on our President to resign to
stop the war
foreign
with hardly any light in the basement
the hostages struggled to work out day
from night
and one of the school teachers smuggled
in a chunk of charcoal to keep a note of
the days and the dead
I think they didn't want us to feel like
humans for the first 10 days there was
no hygiene at all we couldn't even wash
our hands
some of the residents were killed as the
Russians entered the village macailo's
son Victor was one of the first shot
execution style
17 days he was lying in his yard 17 days
he was barefoot and his hands were tied
behind his back
a key part of the prosecution case will
rest on the Russians setting up military
positions in the middle of the Tiny
Village and hiding amongst their homes
the villagers have already been a little
bolstered by the guilty verdicts handed
out to soldiers involved in terrorizing
nadir redchenko's family
her husband was killed her house looted
and guns put to their heads and
Ukrainian lawmakers sentenced three
Russian soldiers to 12 years in prison
in absentia
it's good to get a verdict but not good
they're still walking free because
everyone needs to be held accountable
and if you deliberately came to attack
us you need to be punished
there's much unresolved anguish over
just what happened here
and the torment they endured in the
small village of yehydney
the community which stood in the way of
the Russian troops and their plans to
besiege the capital
and there's a lot of Hope being pinned
on the upcoming war crimes trial to
avenge everything they went through and
those who perished
Alex Crawford Sky News and yahydney in
Northern Ukraine